In this video, we'll look at how we can package our game into an executable for distribution.
To do this, we're going to open our Project Settings and look for the Packaging section.
Come here to Edit, Project Settings, and come down to Packaging.
To do this, we'll open our Project Settings in order to set the maps we want to include and any additional settings for our target platforms.
Inside of Unreal, we can open the Project Settings from the Edit menu and clicking Project Settings.
For this, we are only going to be making sure that the default game map is the one that we have been working on.
However, if you want to set additional levels to be included in a build like you would in Unity,
that can be found in the Advanced Options of the Packaging section in the Project Settings.
You can also set in the Packaging section whether you want your build to be a development, testing, or shipping build.
And if you want to set specific platform settings, you can find those further down the Project Settings list.
So here in our Project Settings, we want to go to Maps and Modes and make sure our session level is set as our default game map.
If you have any other maps that you want to include in a larger project,
you can specify them here in the Advanced Settings of Packaging, all the way down here, a list of maps to include.
We can also see in Packaging, we'll close the Advanced, what kind of build configuration we are going for
and our platform settings for things like Windows or Android, Mac, etc., can be found here in the Platform Settings.
Building our project can be done from the Platforms dropdown, where you then select the platform that you want to build for and hit Package.
You can also change the build type in this dropdown as well, but I'll mention that anecdotally,
I have found that the setting you specify in the Packaging section of the Project Settings can override whatever you pick in this dropdown.
So let's go ahead, we'll go Platforms, Windows, Package Project.
I'm going to go to this folder right here, Builds, Select, and we'll let it do its thing.
The first time packaging your project can take a long time, but the following build times after that should be much faster.
And we're done. All right, so let's go ahead and test it out.
Looks like we can move, and our interactions are working. Fantastic.
So we didn't give ourselves a way to quit.
Quick and easy way to do that, though, is going to be the old Alt-F4.
In the next video, we'll wrap up by taking an overview of everything we've covered today, as well as giving you some new topics to jump into next.